United three six seven preparing for takeoff, please advise copy that three six seven standby                    What is it?
You are one of the brightest students I have ever had and you are failing my class
Did you hear about this? Flight operations were temporarily suspended this afternoon after reports of a mysterious
Aircraft hovering above the airport
I'm gonna need the footage from this entire facility. I want all those passengers in conference room A
We now believe that it was a small drone
No way it's way bigger
When I was a kid, I saw something these lights outside. It wasn't a drone. The guy on TV was lying
You don't
Automatically jump to the most extreme explanation. This isn't some textbook problem. It's more complicated than anything you've ever seen before
This terminal is crawling with federal agents. Why would they still be here if they figured out what it was?
We need to shut him down
FBI is monitoring our computers
Why didn't I see this before?
-think  it's some sort of signal?
That's binary they're using math is a way to communicate and if I'm right it's coming back
There's an opportunity to take a giant leap forward everything is riding on it
What are the most important questions in the world? Is there a god?
Are we alone in the universe? if anyone answered any one of those questions, it would change everything.